[Música]
actualizamos y repasamos las noticias de
la economía en directo América Juan
Pablo saludo para usted nuevamente acá
estamos otra vez para hablar de economía
y para hablar del Reino Unido que sigue
insistiendo en colarse entre los
titulares no logró su objetivo
inflacionario en marzo en cuanto se
ubicó la tasa de este mes pues la tasa
no llegó a su objetivo respecto al mes
anterior todavía sigue en los dos
dígitos y se esperaba que llegara por lo
menos al 9,8% y como lo dice Usted es un
tema que recurrentemente vemos acá
entonces en marzo la inflación
interanual llegó hasta el 10,1% desde el
10,4 de febrero con esto se suma El
séptimo mes consecutivo que Reino Unido
pues tiene una tasa por encima del 10%
vamos a ver los momentos más cruciales
de toda esta de esta pues escenario el
primero es que esperaban llegar a ese 9%
que alcanzaron en abril del 2022 el
11,1% nos recuerda cuando alcanzó esta
inflación mayor de 40 años y el dato de
febrero que es del 10,4 Y aunque hay un
descenso pues como decimos no pues ese
objetivo si revisamos el aumento de
precios por sectores se encarecieron los
alimentos las bebidas no alcohólicas las
actividades de recreación el costo de la
vivienda y los servicios públicos pero
bajaron en el transporte restaurantes y
hoteles Y es que Reino Unido fue el
único país de Europa occidental con una
inflación de dos dígitos en marzo y
recordemos que la inflación de dos
dígitos ha provocado huelgas de
trabajadores del sector público
incluidos médicos enfermeras maestros
funcionarios y maquinistas cuyos
salarios se están viendo
erosionados por el aumento del costo de
vida que dice el ministro de finanzas al
respecto escuchemos
pero es importante decir que aunque
nuestra inflación subyacente es
marginalmente más alta que la de otros
países Alemania por ejemplo tiene una
inflación de los precios de los
alimentos más alta que la nuestra Así
que este es un problema común al que
todos nos enfrentamos cuando hablo con
mis colegas en el fondo monetario
internacional todos muy claro que el
Reino Unido está en el camino correcto
para concentrarse en reducir la
inflación Y si hacemos eso podemos
superar este periodo tan difícil y
asegurarnos de que no estemos teniendo
la misma discusión el próximo año ha
sido todo un acontecimiento la visita de
sergei la Europa a América Latina pasó
por Brasil ahora está en Venezuela y
habló de los planes económicos para ese
país Así es Ángela el ministro de
exteriores ruso aseguró que su país
tiene una agenda rica en Venezuela es
decir enriquecida y habló de acuerdos de
cooperación en energía inversión
finanzas y el sector comercial defendió
a Venezuela de lo que llamó ataques
occidentales en contra de Caracas e hizo
un llamado a la unidad en los países
socios de Moscú la brov visitó
previamente Brasil y también se espera
que pase por Nicaragua y Cuba escuchemos
sus declaraciones
[Música]
acordamos medidas prácticas para
expandir la cooperación comercial y de
inversión y los contactos entre los
círculos empresariales teniendo en
cuenta las realidades actuales tenemos
numerosos en el campo de la producción
de petróleo desarrollo de campos de gas
agricultura medicina y productos
farmacéuticos aumentaremos el volumen y
el ritmo de interacción en todas estas
áreas Y continuaremos utilizando
enérgicamente los mecanismos existentes
para este propósito
bueno y buenas noticias para los
ciudadanos estadounidenses que tienen
cuentas de Facebook pero con ciertas
restricciones Por qué Así es ahí donde
usted y yo nos arrepentimos de no estar
en Estados Unidos porque este mensaje va
para los televidentes que están en ese
país que usaron Facebook entre el 2007 y
el 2022 porque podrían recibir parte de
un acuerdo de escuche la cifra 725
millones de dólares tras una demanda
colectiva contra la compañía meta en la
que se le acusó de haber permitido que
los datos personales de sus usuarios
fueran compartidos con otras compañías
sin el consentimiento de los mismos
Bueno y cómo las personas podrían
acceder a este pago Cuáles son los pasos
a seguir Porque además pues imagínense
si usted me dice los que usaron Facebook
de un año al otro Pues es un montón de
Así es vamos a dar los requisitos el
primero es haber sido usuario de
Facebook entre el 24 de mayo de 2007
exactamente y el 22 de diciembre de 2022
eso lo válido para usuarios de estadios
de Estados Unidos y pueden hacer la
solicitud por medio del portal oficial
de meta que estamos viendo en este
momento y pues tienen hasta el 25 de
agosto para presentar su reclamo los
pagos serán otorgados después de que se
verifiquen las cuántas personas
califican para recibir el dinero del
acuerdo y el dinero puede ser recibido
por cuentas bancarias directas o la
plataformas como PayPal que le parece
pues me parece que va a ser muy
complicado con tanta gente pero si le
parece vamos ya nuestra cifra del día
que es un tema que además les compete a
las nuevas generaciones a nuestros hijos
Si es el caso y usted nos cuenta Así es
según la ONU se espera que A mediados de
este año India tenga 2,9 millones de
personas más que china según el informe
sobre el estado de la población del
fondo de población de las Naciones
Unidas no sé si usted Cuál será el país
entonces que ocupará el tercer lugar
porque con esto queda India China y el
tercer lugar queda para no usted me
cuenta Estados Unidos es el otro Bueno
estamos Juan Pablo preparándonos o más
bien falta de preparaciones lo que
tenemos para la realidad de las megas
ciudades y de las poblaciones que van en
aumento y en crecimiento en el mundo no
usted ha hablado ya y sus compañeros de
economía sobre los efectos que tendrá el
hecho de que china deje de ser el país
más poblado del mundo así es y ahí es
donde china aparece en la Esfera
internacional porque vemos como por
ejemplo estas semanas veíamos que
Indonesia entra también a la Esfera de
reemplazar esos suministros de china en
temas comerciales hablamos también de
Singapur de Corea del Sur y ahí es donde
se ve la balanza de Cuáles son los
países que van a entrar como a defender
Pues el escenario de sus ideales por un
lado occidente por el otro lado pues el
tema de Asia y con esto también vemos de
que debemos de que Estados Unidos pues
ocupa el tercer lugar en población pero
el primer lugar como Economía del mundo
Entonces ya veremos Cómo se puede jugar
a la balanza no no claro y además está
el tema dificultad entre los dos grandes
retos no por un lado el aumento de la
población que además América Latina va a
ser un protagonista y África también de
este aumento poblacional que esperamos
para las próximas décadas mientras que
otros países se quedan sin personas para
que en el futuro sean quienes sostengan
la economía el sistema de las pensiones
para que sean las personas que puedan
permitir que se sigan desarrollando Y
eso es un caso de Japón no algunos dicen
que hasta Los japoneses en algún momento
van a dejar de existir sobre la faz de
la Tierra así es Y eso también lo están
revisando Incluso el gobierno está
pidiendo que las personas vayan a vivir
si algunas ciudades están dando
incentivos para que las personas lleguen
financieros y que pues vean en las
principales ciudades de este país lo
cierto Juan Pablo es que sabemos que
china se despertó tarde de esta
finalización de la política del hijo
único ya en este momento las mujeres no
quieren maternidades impuestas O al
menos no lo ven como un destino natural
y nosotros estamos viendo las
consecuencias vamos a ver qué pasa más
adelante Le agradezco muy amena la
conversación En todo caso y este es un
tema que hemos tratado y que Seguiremos
desarrollando Pues en nuestras emisiones
de directo a América y de France 24 y
seguro revisaremos también en la
economía en un especial seguramente
Muchas gracias Juan Pablo y seguimos con
los deportes si le parece sí mañana con
más
[Música]